>>Jeff: I think this
data helps demonstrate.
This student organized it from
greatest to least before he graphed it.
>>Teacher: That is interesting.
>>Teacher: This one is counting
by sixes, twelves, fives.
>>Jessica: Because our
teachers look at student work,
they really see what
students are thinking
and how they're expressing their
understand from the classroom,
and they're better able to guide
and facilitate a deeper
level of student learning.
>>Taryn: So it's two ways of them being
able to think about creating this graph.
>>Jeff: At Two Rivers, we really care
about our whole community as learners.
>>Taryn: So what did we do so far?
>>Jeff: That includes not just
our students, but also our staff.
>>Jessica: The reason we
look at student work is
to help teachers become better teachers.
Student work is the expression
of what kids are learning,
and so if you're thinking about,
how am I doing as a teacher,
there's your evidence.
>>Taryn: So when you guys get with
your partner, you're going to work
to create a, what type of graph?
>>Students: Bar graph.
>>Taryn: Bar graph.
>>We just started doing bar graphs with
them last week, so it's relatively new.
>>Make sure your name is on it, please.
>>The process of looking at
the work will really help me
as I'm planning the rest of
this sequence of lessons.
>>Jessica: One of the
most powerful things
that we do is the looking
at student work protocol.
>>Jeff: Taryn today brought
a set of student work.
The group of teachers and
I took a look at that work,
to give her some insights into,
what do her kids really understand
around this technical
skill of creating a graph?
>>Taryn: So the task that they had was,
Miss Cynthia is ordering
new shirts for next year.
>>The protocol starts where I
give a very short introduction
to what the work is.
>>How can Miss Cynthia create
a graph to represent the data
about the different colored
shirts she ordered?
And what you'll see is, the chart
with the different colored shirts,
and there's different numbers.
So it was different shading.
>>The team looks at the work,
and they look at it silently,
just thinking about how they
would respond to the task,
and then looking at how students did.
After that, there is about five
minutes where the presenter is silent
and you're just talking
about things you notice
and things you wonder about the task.
>>Teacher: I notice that there's
three different sets of numbers.
>>Teacher: I noticed that in one of
the sets, it's only two digit numbers.
I wonder which students
got which sets of numbers.
>>Jeff: After about five minutes,
we shift the protocol to comments,
where there is analysis, and we
can start to put our own judgments
into what we are seeing with the data.
>>I feel like what the
kids needed to grapple
with in this problem
was really around scale.
>>Teacher: Look at how
different they look,
based on what the scale
that the chose was.
>>Carolina: I feel like there's
this profound vulnerability
in being silent while your team
looks at the work that you're doing.
It removes you from the conversation,
so that you can really focus
on what people are saying,
because you're listening.
>>Taryn: Following that,
there is a discussion.
>>I think what was happy for me
to hear was you guys noticed.
What we wanted them to grapple
with was the scale on this one.
>>That's the part where we
really talk about, okay, well,
what are the next steps
that students need?
>>Teacher: Thinking about this story,
if we look at Matthew's
and then someone else.
>>Taryn: It all of a sudden looks
like way more shirts were ordered.
>>Jeff: It does.
>>Carolina: I think you're
designing a graph
to tell a story of something, you know.
Scale matters, right?
>>Taryn: I feel like I get concrete
feedback and concrete steps to take.
>>I like the idea that you guys said.
What is the story, like what do
we want people to think about it?
>>So I really like the idea
of graphing telling a story.
>>What else could that
graph be telling me?
>>So I think that's going
to be our focus.
>>Has anyone ever thought
about stories in math before?
I don't know if you're
going to believe me,
but the bar graphs you
create tell a story.
>>Jessica: Getting feedback
is daunting at first,
but after people experience
it, they relish it.
>>Student: This is how
much people like yellow.
This is how much people like green.
>>Taryn: The same way students
get ideas from each other,
I get a lot of ideas from my colleagues.
I absolutely love it and I need it.